but let's talk about the
israeli-palestinian conflict I've said
many times that to have a real chance at
restarting meaningful peace negotiations
in the israeli-palestinian conflict on
the side of Israel Benjamin Netanyahu's
right-wing administration and very very
extreme coalition needs to be out of
power they have shown that they have no
credibility as real arbiters of peace or
potential arbiters of peace and at the
same time I've said that on the
Palestinian side the terrorist group
Hamas as well as Fatah probably need to
be out of power in Gaza and the West
Bank if we are going to have meaningful
progress in terms of peace negotiations
we have some possibly good news out of
the latter there are five Palestinian
parties in Gaza and the West Bank that
are going to be running on a joint list
in the upcoming akak Tober 8th elections
these are local elections in 300
municipalities village councils and
regional councils under the name
Democratic Alliance and the senior
officials of these five parties are
trying to position what is described as
a leftist bloc as an alternative to
Fatah and Hamas which is exactly what is
needed in Gaza and the West Bank they're
going to run on ideas like equality
between men and women Wow that would be
a huge positive change in the region
they are going to run on resistance to
corruption that would be a huge positive
change in the region Fatah and Hamas are
a disaster in that area this is
important number one because these
elections are expected to be the first
elections in all of the Palestinian
territories since Hamas took over
control of the Gaza Strip in 2007 and
Hamas has effectively boycotted local
elections based on the Fatah controlled
Palestinian Authority so I think that
this is very very good now not everybody
likes it the Islamic Jihad movement in
Palestine doesn't like it they announced
a few days ago that they're going to
boycott these elections saying this is
not at all an appropriate way forward
they want Hamas and Fatah to instead
work together to achieve national you
that may be achievable anything good for
the populations would not by Hamas and
Fatah working together and to give you a
little background pIJ this this group is
a paramilitary organization dating back
to 1981 whose objective is the
destruction of the State of Israel so if
you're trying to make moves that will
get you closer to productive peace talks
maybe don't take the advice of the group
that for the last 35 years has sought
the destruction of Israel now I want to
restate louis these are local elections
so this is not a national election it
could potentially be the first step in a
similar democratic alliance being formed
at the national level i've laid out my
plan many times and a key port point of
that plan
no netanyahu in israel no hamas and
fatah representing the Palestinian
people in Gaza and the West Bank and
maybe and I'm really looking for the
silver lining here this could be the
first baby step in the direction of
Hamas and Fatah not representing
Palestinians nationally in peace talks
and your mic is not right that's yeah
that's a wonderful thing I'm all about
that I totally support that the problem
is that Hamas Fatah the extremist groups
that support Hamas and Fatah are just
that through the extremist groups and
these are groups that will kill
opposition right in order to stay in
power so it is a first step but they
need to be very very careful one month
before our presidential election here on
November 8th October 8th these local
elections scheduled to happen in Gaza
and the West Bank we will follow it and
we will see what comes from this maybe
I'm hopeful cautiously optimistic that
this could be a first step in
eliminating terrorist group Hamas as
well as Fatah from representing in that
term it doesn't make any sense because
they really don't represent the
interests of the Palestinian people from
representing the Palestinian people in
potential future negotiations with
Israel let's take a break I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and we have a tremendous
program for you today we will finally
win again with today's show Warby Parker
is offering a free five day home Tryon
to give you
the opportunity to check out their
glasses I personally wear Warby Parker
glasses when I'm not wearing my contact
lenses and I also started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trialed comm slash TDPS
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like $300 for prescription glasses high
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing